-My next guest
is a terrific actor
who you know from
"Game of Thrones," "Narcos,"
and he stars
in "The Mandalorian."
He's unbelievable
Well, you can also see him in
"Wonder Woman 1984,"
which will be in select theaters
and IMAX Christmas Day,
and it will also be available
on the same day on HBO Max.
Here is Pedro Pascal!
Yeah, look at you, buddy.
It's always great to see you.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Look at you, man.
I love your hair.
-You like it?
-Yeah. I like the relaxed...
-It's kind of out of control
and you don't know
where it's going to go.
-...all alone
in the studio look.
I like it a lot.
-Hey, "Wonder Woman 1984"
comes out next week,
and tomorrow is the season
finale of "The Mandalorian."
This is a pretty amazing time
to be you right now
in this crazy time
and this crazy world,
but I just want to thank you
for all the content
and the stuff you have us
look forward to.
It's really helpful for us.
-Well, yeah. I mean, as you
say it, it makes me sweat.
-Nah, no pressure. No pressure.
Although, I'm assuming you're
getting phone calls like crazy
about like "Hey, can you hook me
up with a Baby Yoda doll?
Can you get me a Baby Yoda?"
-I'm totally way ahead of it.
-You knew it was going
to happen.
-I've been my friends',
all the ones with kids anyway,
my friends' favorite person for
a while.
Not that I get much,
to be honest with you.
I stole a little Lego piece
from the very first
kind of Mandalorian Star Wars
toy experience that I had,
and I was like, "Oh,
dude I'm going to take this,
literally this size Lego.
I'm just putting it my pocket
and I'll take it with me.
And I got a call."
-Oh, they knew?
-Oh, yeah.
-Wow!
How are you with keeping
secrets?
How do you keep Baby Yoda
a secret
to the whole entire world?
-That was the first time that
I kept a secret
and I didn't even tell my --
like, I told no one.
You know, Kristen Wiig was on
your show just a little bit ago.
-Yep.
She was talking about how good
she follows the rules.
-Yeah. She didn't tell anyone.
She didn't mention --
not allowed to really
talk about it now even.
-Yeah.
Well, so she had this like
cocktail thing,
get-together thing in London
before we started shooting
officially. You know?
And, you know, for everyone
to kind of meet and chat
and get together.
And I met two of her very close
friends.
And they were asking what I was
doing in the movie.
And I was like, "Oh, and I --,"
I was like, "Well, you know, and
this guy, and --
who sort of is alongside --
Kristen.
I'm sure Kristen has
told you everything.
They're like, "No, no, no."
She says she's not allowed
to talk about it." And these are
like two of her best friends."
-Yeah. She takes it seriously.
-I literally told
the entire plot
to my Uber driver
on the way to that --
to those cocktails.
He was like, "So what are you
doing in London?"
I was like "Oh,
I'm shooting a movie."
They're like,
"What's the movie?"
I was like, "It's a big movie,
you know, it's 'Wonder Woman.'"
And he was like,
"What's the character?"
And I was like,
"Oh, well I got to start
from the beginning here, so --"
-Oh, my gosh.
-This is what he does.
-This is what happens.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Anyway, I was like, you know,
he doesn't care
or he's not going to believe me.
So --
-He kept your secret, man.
Did you ever see him again?
-I realized once Kristen was,
like, not telling her,
you know, she wasn't telling her
fiancé at the time.
She wasn't telling anybody.
-I've seen the movie.
She still wouldn't tell me
what she did in the movie.
I know everything.
She was like,
"Yeah. Yeah. I'm so close.
Why ruin it now?"
Like, I don't care.
I'm totally fine with you.
-Well, I'm here to ruin it.
What do you want to know?
-[ Chuckles ]
No, I won't let you do that.
How did you get cast
in the movie?
Did you know Patty before this,
or --
-Yeah. I had met Patty.
I worked with her on a pilot
that never saw the light of day.
And this was a role that
had a very kind of small part
in the pilot actually,
so I just got to work with her
for a couple days, but was an
incredible fan of hers.
Like, I'd seen "Monster"
and everything she had done
on TV, and so I actually got
a call from the movie's producer
Chuck Roven who I was working
with on something at the time,
and he said that Patty wanted to
talk to me about a role
in "Wonder Woman," and I talked
with her and had this
incredible conversation with her
on Skype.
And she described this really,
really cool character.
But I didn't have a script.
And I also just wasn't really
registering
that she wanted me
to play the part.
I didn't see how that would be
possible without, you know,
killing myself trying to get it,
really.
Because, I mean, I've done much
more for a guest spot
on, like, "Law & Order"
you know?
Criminal intent.
You know what I'm saying?
-That's the secret
for any actor out there.
-Three callbacks for it.
-Wow.
Yeah, isn't that amazing, right?
-Yeah.
-So then I had to fly to London
to go and have
like a, you know --
I had the part.
And they were just asking me to
go to London to do fittings
and to sit down with Patty
and to talk about it
and everything like that.
I still didn't have a script.
And I wasn't asking --
I wasn't asking for anything.
You understand what I'm saying?
-Yeah, yeah.
-I was just like,
"Let me be a part of this."
I got to read the script
leaving London.
I read it on the plane.
You know?
And I didn't -- you know,
it could have been, you know --
It could have been a piece of
furniture and I would have
said yes to it.
I kept on seeing his name on the
pages and I was like,
"I can't believe this."
-You gave it to your Uber driver
like,
"What do you think about this?"
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. The flight attendant.
Do you think I should --
Did I do the right thing?
-You got any notes for this?
I don't know. I could read it
over the loud speaker
if you want me to.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to show everyone
a clip from the movie.
Here is Pedro Pascal
in "Wonder Woman 1984."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Well, aren't you resourceful?
-Come with me.
-No, I don't think so.
Remove this woman, please...
permanently.
-[ Grunting ]
[ Gunfire ]
Aah!
-[ Grunting ]
[ Both grunt, groan ]
-Are you okay?
-I don't know.
♪♪
[ Grunts ]
-Pedro Pascal,
"Wonder Woman 1984"
will be in select theaters
and IMAX Christmas Day
and available the same day
on HBO Max.
Thank you so much for being here
as always, buddy.
it's always good to see you.
You keep crushing it on
everything.
Oh, my gosh.
"Wonder Woman," "Mandalorian."
Come on.
Happy holidays to you, bud.